desean watson is indeed
so freaking awesome look at this four
thousand eight hundred and twenty three
passing yards for a four and twelve team
so nothing around him he's got
nothing around him he had seven games
this year
with a passer rating of 110 or more
and lost them tom brady for his entire
career
has three games that he's lost where he
had a passer rating in excess of 110.
desean watson had seven in one year that
tells you that the cupboard around
desean watson chris
is bare we talked about this last hour
as it relates to the attractiveness of
the job
there is some heavy lifting that needs
to be done in houston
to put the team around desean watson
that he needs
having the franchise quarterback is not
the ending it's the beginning
actually having offensive and defensive
lines is really the beginning
but the beginning of being a truly
competitive team is having a franchise
quarterback
they don't have enough around the
franchise quarterback
to be anywhere near as competitive as
they need no
i mean that's why you know i i feel like
he's the
the beacon or the great shining example
this year
for for people to understand like it's
not all about the quarterback
it's not all about the quarterback you
got to build a damn team
that's what the name of the game is you
know desean watson
it's undeniable i mean that he's one of
the five or six best quarterbacks nobody
can watch football and not think that
when you watch the sean watson
it's just not possible what is there
that's not good or not awesome
everything he does is top level
moving in the pocket awesome throwing of
the football
awesome touch power whatever you want to
say it's all awesome
running out of the pocket extending
plays awesome
toughness awesome leadership awesome
charisma
awesome i mean the guy's the man but
there's only so much he can do
you know i mean yeah four and 12
football team
where they were in most of the games
because of him but i mean they they're a
one and 15
they're all in 16 team without desean
watson that's how special he is that's
what he's done for their football team
and yeah
man they got a lot of work to do there
down in houston on both sides of the
ball
he said after the game on sunday when
they lost to the tennessee titans
there's no real foundation in view
yeah everyone sees it that would scare
the crap out of me if i was a texans fan
because i'm not saying it's going to
happen now
he just signed that big contract it's
not the easiest thing in the world to do
to
deal with the cap issues and the
guarantees and whatnot
but they got one year maybe two before
desean watson starts thinking
he's better off somewhere else
potentially and i'm not saying that i
know anything there i never do i'm
putting myself in that situation
or son nephew cousin
friend client anyone you care about
what advice would you give to them and
the advice at some point is you got to
get out of here
and if a franchise quarterback isn't all
in this gets back to the carson wentz
point
if you're not all-in
you know it's one thing for the team to
say to a running back or a receiver
defensive end
sorry we we have your rights under
contract for the next three years
you need your franchise quarterback to
be the boss on the shop floor
the guy who's busting his butt the guy
who's rallying his teammates the guy
who's setting the example for the kind
of work ethic that they want
showing up early staying late studying
film if you get a quarterback who
doesn't want to be there and he just
decides
i'm just going to do the bare minimum
because apparently everyone else is
doing the bare minimum two
that's not sustainable so if he does
decide he wants out
chris uh i i don't think the texans have
any choice but to
to accommodate that if he comes to that
conclusion
at some point in the future i'm not
saying he will i'm not saying he's there
but when you hear a comment there's no
real foundation in view and everyone
sees it that puts the team on notice
they better get a foundation in view
or he's going to start looking around
yeah well he's not happening he's not
the kind of guy that's ever going to be
like oh well i'm not going to try hard
or do anything like that he's just not
so it'll be to where yeah it could be
two years from now or whatever and if
it's still the same crappy looking
football team
he's he will let it be known i mean
there's just no way
but i think his point is real and i
think he does say that tactically in a
right way
outright way out loud to kind of let it
be known through ownership team like
what
what do we have here right now what is
the foundation
me like and only me where are we going
jj watt you know it's over he's still a
good player but you're not building
anything around him
other than that what else is there
really to build around in houston
that's what's scary and that's where
it's going to be a really you know
uphill climb for whoever comes in there
to be the gm
head coach and do that but the number
one thing is like you said
they got to make him happy that's where
i look at it and just go
man eric the enemy with the houston
texans
that just makes so much sense to me you
know
his way with quarterbacks i think he's
the right guy that could
you know light a fire under the
organization keep desean calm while they
build the team and keep his eyes on the
prize down the road and everything like
that
i'm hoping that's what happens you know
like i said i'd love to see eric
be enemy one because he deserves it and
then two
i'd like to see deshaun watson get a
chance to play in that offense
they are talking to deshaun watson about
what he's looking for in a coach and
there are some who would say
that's not the player's role never give
the player that kind of power we've had
that conversation
over the years chris not you and i per
se but it's come up in
the media when brett favre politics for
free agents when
when other quarterbacks say this is what
i want that's what i want russell wilson
doing that last year
my position is this if you want the
quarterback to basically be a quasi
member of management
and you do you want him to be the guy
who's spreading your message in the
locker room and setting the example and
setting the tone
you need to give him some management
rights you need to let him have a seat
at the table
for the big decisions and you better
have a coach that desean watson feels
good about
because he surely doesn't feel good
about
a lot of what's going on on the roster
right now i think what you're saying
coach is a starting point
yeah i get you you got to make him think
he's a part of this
you know not that he has to make the
decision but
like you said it's about keeping him
happy he's their prized possession
and it's two years the world can change
so let's keep him happy and and go along
here but they should be building around
watson we know that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports